o latitude pessoal de quem fala andar
que sejam muito bem vindos e irmã em um
velho leão é tomar café e desde já peço
desculpa por não ter andado colocar
muitos filhos mas recentemente o sujeito
faz com isso que é um evento em outubro
se basicamente eu fiquei sem bosh que é
muito cansado quando cheguei a casa e
prontidão que está a fazer sim vidas
porque senão ainda procurava é a
instituição da garganta não há hipótese
nenhuma para esta coisa aqui no gente no
meu lado eu não sei como é que eu vou
tirar isto mas é vamos lá então jogar
mário romancini lou ye joide bull era
latente na coxa e botafogo que é muito
meu amigo é ganhar isto sim banda larga
caixas já morreram em calma eu tenho que
evitar estes argumentos parecem pois né
está tudo escuro amigo tenho uma imagem
dunga já se prepara um homem eu acho que
era isso nem perceber porque ela parecia
muito rápido calma lá que eu nem te ter
este mapa parece muito simples vai
acontecer alguma coisa o botafogo noite
e não os mataram luigi meu calma lá e
não posso ir na lava em casa percebeu
que um vampiro foi o pbn não vou apanhar
a este estado homônimo meu carro não não
caí na lava não podem agora só que aí
weiwei por ser aqui que ela imagina toda
vez eu já sei como consegui calma eu sou
eu que usavam brigas outra vez não sabe
quem é manoel luigi não fizeram muito
mala eu vou brigar no ide calma e se
esquiva de estudos carece manejada
já fui amigo eu consigo matar atirando
pra frente amanhã o toque mas o quintal
de casa abrigo sério que passaram lá não
há e não a mario silva tomiu não pode
ser italiano ritmo através mil só tem um
irmão está mentira eu vou tirar o craque
já pra matar que os gastos muito bem dar
que isso mesmo anda solta o gato capital
eu sou muito eu sou muito eu sou muito
sobre o outro foi o que o meu parecer
bifes de pessoas mortas
está visto já não está nada disto meu
irmão brigas aqui com caraças
andam a enganar quem ok ok não acaba por
aí eu não pode ser injusto eu fui aquela
cara tranquilo vamos lançar novo eu acho
que só tem cinco vidas acho que é isso
aqui vou ter que passar isso foi uma
sorte grande e lá também
consegui aqui o sistema difícil calma
calma são brigas com a palavra e
exatamente lá também estava o meu irmão
luigi ainda isso eu não posso e não
posso sertanejos porque não fique sem o
lucho acho que já percebi que a técnica
diz né
ana lá não zelam brigas ok ok é
exatamente seus matar eu fique sem luz e
isso é mau isso não pode acontecer
porque quando vocês ficam cirurgia
quando capa preta aparece com os que
passaram aqui pessoal já percebi já
percebeu o esquema é vocês não use no
haiti vocês não podem matar as duas
drogas drogas flores das drogas botafogo
já está pensando em alguma peça também
foi muito com o que se passou para
remover o produto né
isso eu não posso apanhar o escudo não
estou ligado à apanha isso porque é o
que estamos bem e acho que espera possa
fugir de hoje e só não morri posses
nível meu advogado o caso eu acho tenho
uma vida filho da mãe um irmão para não
chatear camada passarem drogas
aí lá mario amor né
calma calma não vai pegar agora eu acho
que o pessoal está em curso
[Música]
calma calma calma anda isso que manda lá
eu acho o caso eu posso agora dois
chutes que esta poderia ser a minha tem
justin deu este jogo é injusto meu e que
eu chamo de todos obtidos justo
pessoalmente procuro não votei que calma
zé manel do face oculta foi pedida para
foi isso que matou a menina nunca vou
ter que faltar assim e agora passado o
top 14 apóiam anda anda com pessoas com
as escapadas de gol
é este o demônio eu este jogo é tudo
fofoca em demônio anda lá ok não está a
acontecer nada estranho muito estranho
alunos é vampiro anda sair daqui um
filme eu sei eu sei meu pé era passei eu
acho que vai acontecer aqui alguma coisa
senão pode ter sido só assim eu fui
mesmo calma calma e agora eu tenho para
onde ir pra quem é preciso nível como
foi em dobro para seu repto era não sei
o que é que está a passar aqui um homem
morto meu calo e pronto está em jogo é o
google não sei que estou aqui
o jogo traz bem
google pessoal am é então é isso pessoal
nós vamos ficar por aqui com este mario
panchita espero que vocês tenham gostado
aí na descrição vai estar também o sono
enquanto x é que é um jogo está muito
bom também e você que aconteceu ainda
não é isso só espero que vocês tenham
gostado já sabem quanto o vosso apoio lá
e que favorito fiquem bem lance mãe
[Música]